bon là on va régler quelque chose des
campagnes de salissage c'est pas gentil
alors pour commencer le débat sur des
meilleures bases je demanderai aux chefs
de nommer au moins une qualité de leurs
adversaires ce jeudi j'aimerais entendre
parler de l'environnement la politique
étrangère de la survie de radio canada
ainsi que la survie de la langue
française hors québec
j'aimerais bien entendre ce qu'ils
veulent en avoir parlé de l'oléoduc
énergie est il habite mais parler de
monsanto dans milk a parlé des jeunes
je le dis c'est parler d'économie et
justin trudeau je ne les connais pas je
te comprend l'exploitation pétrolière
projets 2010 venant le président à
l'inter de la stabilité dans ma bulle
khadra qui incarne le changement juste
être d'autres dira-t-il internautes
allemands mieux thomas mulcair et gilles
duceppe s'en prendre à avec des manceaux
npd pour regagner de l'appui au québec
on va simplement par les devils
esséniens vous parle un peu trop
d'économies pas si des nouvelles
technologies vient est certainement
parce irish je prédis que monsieur
duceppe risque d'être très dur très
critique à l'endroit d'une bd en
contrepartie conscient qu'une remontée
du bloc au québec et à leur avantage me
suis reprise plutôt est ce que de droit
trop embêté monsieur je pense que je ne
sais pas tout faire pour trouver son
parti que thomas broker marcher sur un
fil de fer pour paver paire de bottes ni
au canada ni au québec que stephen
harper une parler de ces valeurs qui
sont nos valeurs et que justin trudeau
va aimer le canada
les débuts sont souvent synonymes des
clichés ce jeudi je m'attends donc à ce
que les mouches changement ensemble et
lits de chez soi sur utilisé sans
réellement prendre deux sens concret et
se calme pas depuis des lignes de comme
prépare chez question de faire rejouer à
question une focus gmail et des pièces
avec mon cousin que sogeti au débat des
chefs
j'ai vu sa peinture au moins cinq fois
leur canadien qu'est-ce qui venons
encore une fois parler de sa prestation
et je songe l'économie fois que je serai
toujours à débarquer avec une barre de
garde mais cela s'applique mais comme
j'ai dis soit en civil un peu ça fera
évidemment parfaitement clair justin
trudeau m le québec mais ton amour avec
le canada gilles duceppe n'est pas
contre le canada mais bon le québec et
un bulgare sera prêt pour le changement
monsieur rapport de me rappeler à quel
point nous sommes en sécurité avec un
bon gouvernement conservateur abc motors
lui son budget mais il va balancer et
justin trudeau une phase très beau aux
yeux de justin trideau barre de la
classe moyenne que stimulant pour la
classe moyenne
pas question de rendre l'utile à
l'agréable
j'ai créé un bingo débat des chefs
lorsqu'il se rendra le doigt lorsque
trudeau restera un texte où lorsque
manqué parlera de sa grande famille
cochez la case correspondant va tenter
une carte complète